with exactly two weeks to go before the
midterm president Trump used the migrant
caravan to rally his political base in
Houston last night on the first day of
early voting in Texas the president
campaigned for Republican senator Ted
Cruz remember they were bitter rivals in
the 2016 GOP presidential race and the
newest polls show Cruz with a
seven-point lead over his Democratic
challenger Congressman Beto O'Rourke
Nancy Cordes is there in Houston Nancy
good morning good morning
typically the president wouldn't need to
campaign here in ruby-red Texas
especially for a one-time rival but Ted
Cruz is going up against a well-funded
outspoken Democrat in a race that could
help determine the balance of power in
the Senate so it behooves both mr. Trump
and mr. Cruz to bury the hatchet
that is an assault on our country here
in Houston president Trump continued his
attacks on the thousands of Honduran
migrants making their way to the US
border in that Caravan you have some
very bad people we need a wall built
fans you need to vote for Ted Cruz he
shared the stage with Texas senator Ted
Cruz
who got a verbal embrace from his former
foe the people of Texas are going to
react a man who has become a really good
friend of mine
the president admitted he and Cruz
weren't so chummy in 2016 it got nasty
when they were two of the last
Republicans in the presidential
primaries Donald you're a sniveling
coward Ted Cruz the biggest liar I've
ever met is that lyin Ted anymore it is
beautiful then now they have a shared
opponent of them Democrats better
o'rourke to those who say a Democrat
can't win in Texas you say what we're
running to represent Americans Texans
human beings and when we see past the
labels and the partisanship and the
pettiness of the moment we transcend
that with two weeks to go Democrats are
also bringing out their big guns get the
hell up and
take back the country former Vice
President Biden was in Tampa former
President Obama in Las Vegas right now
we can tip the balance of power back to
you the American people
early voting started yesterday here in
Texas with the turnout smashing previous
midterm records it's too early to say
what that means for the candidates Gail
but it does show the high interest in
this year's elections P Nancy I'm still
thinking about lyin Ted - beautiful -
I'm just saying all sudden things look
brighter and nicer
thank you very much Nancy importing from
Texas there's a there's an election
elections make bedfellows there you go